saw a column by dan wetzel talking about
what's going on with Wake Forest and
Danny columnist for yahoo sports but you
know now you're finding out who got what
and what did they do with it and it's
almost like you know Louisville says hey
we got it but we didn't really use it
and I think it's dan wetzel was pointing
out sir like attempted murder I didn't
murder anybody but I was trying to I we
didn't cheat but we tried to and you're
getting stolen goods but you didn't use
anything there dan wetzel yahoo sports
columnist joins us now the recent
article the dirt keeps piling up at
louisville under Tom Jurich swatch their
athletic director huh good morning Dan
how you feeling I'm good doing well dan
how are you good good you're fired up
about this with Louisville participation
in this why well I I'm not the one who's
going to come on and lecture anyone
about ethics so i don't really that's
that part doesn't bother me more the
humor of the louisville response which
is yeah we did it as you were saying but
we already knew those plays trust us on
that I mean you know got caught with the
cheat sheet in class and then said but I
had studied really well that's why I got
the hundred not i mean it's it's just
not really a plausible bit and then the
best part of the whole louisville
response is that he's Tom George is
disappointed that this has brought undue
attention on the coaching staff as
they're trying to prepare fogey thoughts
and prayers damn those more guys got the
top of secret plays that they didn't
have to use or didn't use according to
them who previously said they didn't get
the secret place I mean come on the
whole thing is it's fairly comical I
love a great college scandal especially
when it doesn't involve like you know we
have Baylor with Penn State like serious
stuff I love a great college scandal
when it's about who stole what from whom
that's good good stuff how deep does
this go where's the ACC going to take
this
we can laugh now I don't think it's
followed the louisville coach or any
coach that got this information I would
not be laughing out of yet a lawyer's
office right now this is probably stolen
information wake forest is already
called it proprietary and as much as you
know look I can't get that worked up
over it but it probably is stolen stolen
information and that's a that's a crime
and you know you have the Louisville
statement basically says one assistant
gets the information from his old friend
the radio host the radio broadcaster he
then hands it over he's an offensive
coach he then hands over the place or
the schemes to the whole defensive staff
or the defensive coaches so there's a
lot of people in Louisville that are
involved in this and then you have to
say how does does Bobby Petrino know
about it how would Bobby tree no not
know about it exactly what preparation
for Game would go down were a number of
coaches on both sides of the football
know about this and he does it and then
you're going to say are you all in
possession of stolen property did you
see you know this is this could very
well become a big huge issue for those
involved even if it's not necessarily
that serious of an issue from afar I get
the competent this speaks right to the
basic competition of the game and I
think that's where the ACC's got to step
in that's really why I just surprised
Louisville didn't come out and say look
we should be better than this we don't
think you know we're going to suspend
the guy for a bowl game our coaches even
if given this information should be
smart enough to say I don't want it
that's cheating I don't want to be
involved in that instead they're just
basically saying we don't care at all
it's probably not the best look going
forward when this thing snowballs into a
bigger scandal should the NCAA Guinea
moldiness you know maybe I i lecture the
NCA a lot about not getting involved in
things like you know when they get
involved in you know legal matters we're
going to discipline because of you know
assaults or sexual assaults on campus or
the Penn State thing this speaks to the
actual competition of the game
and so I think that's what the NCAA is
therefore that's what the ACC's office
therefore this is football and I would
not have a problem with both those
entities said what's going on here this
I expect this to be pretty wide-ranging
if this guy was handing out secrets for
multiple years to multiple you know
trying to give it out or getting it out
to different teams then you know you're
going to have a lot of schools involved
and you're gonna have schools that
aren't all in the ACC involved how do we
find out about this initially that
Louisville had this like who if this was
in the SEC it would never come out right
I mean they're professionally yeah but
like three guys would have mysteriously
driven their cars off a bridge somewhere
outside of Dothan Alabama they just
would have disappeared into the night in
the SEC we'd never get the story no what
happened was and this is this is really
the biggest turn over the years sloppy
sloppy execution by Louise oh hey they
had the information and they had it at
their stadium and laying around
somewhere we don't know for sure and
Wake Forest came for their walk through
the day before the game at Papa John's
stadium and found the information and
then they didn't they say they didn't
run the reason the plays were run is
because they knew really they'll have
them so then they make a big complaint
Louisville of course feigns outrage like
Casablanca like you know what gambling
here I'd have no way and and then wake
forest starts looking into how this
information you get out they find out
it's the rate they test everybody they
find out it's the through text messages
and emails it's the it's the radio
broadcaster who had access to kind of
all access to the program who used to be
an assistant coach at Wake Forest and he
was the one who was doling out the
information according to wake forest
he's dan wetzel yahoo sports columnist I
also brought this up and I know you've
written a lot about deflategate with the
Patriots and I wonder with what's
happened with the Giants and the
steelers and I don't know to what degree
but we're not covering it the Giants did
file a complaint during the game to the
NFL but apparently not an official
complaint whatever that means I get the
feeling this is the league office saying
you know what we probably made a mistake
with the Patriots and Tom Brady the
first time around we're not going down
this rabbit hole again what do you think
that's exactly what they did looked with
the opportunity to do deflategate again
because it's the same thing happened the
Colts got an intercepted pass from Tom
Brady they go to the sideline they
measure the ball outdoors mind you and
of course it comes in under 12.5 two
balls of the Steelers got or the giants
got two balls from the Steelers they
measure the balls outdoors in December
they come in under two points 12.5
originally the NFL thought the ball
should never be below to 12.5 so the
12.4 you're cheating if it's 11.4 it's a
huge cheating right yep so they go down
this whole five-month investigation
millions of dollars a federal case they
aren't there grilling every guy on the
staff what's your nickname give me all
your text messages every single thing on
this one they have the exact same start
to the scandal and the NFL just says
forget away in doing this given the
chance to do to play gay again they did
the exact opposite and there's two
questions these are you say okay the
balls we found out the footballs were
never outside of the control of the
referee okay then how do they get to
11.4 you know my thing with the
footballs at the New England I
originally thought New England did it
but the more you talk to scientists see
more to talk to professor's the
footballs were never deflated in the
first place and we're never tampered
with it just didn't happen there's no
deflating and deflate gate and I think
the NFL knows that now and through
actions if not words that are
acknowledging that they did it all wrong
the first time before I let you go
you're a smart guy could you decipher
what the Commissioner is saying when he
was asked about the Steelers Giants
possible to fleet gate to what I'm aware
of Bob eNOS is that the protocols we
went back look to make sure that the
protocols were followed properly they
were the Giants had asked us about it
during the game we went back we checked
that they were properly followed so all
of the league protocols being properly
followed there's no further follow-up on
that what does it mean oh yes
absolutely yes yeah well he was saying
that they that that though no equipment
guy got a hold of the footballs from for
for a minute or two before the game I
think that's what staying there was no
pro but again how do you explain the
11.4 because they don't want to
acknowledge remember last year they
changed their game operations manual to
say that it's select games security and
the rest would take footballs measure
them at halftime record the numbers and
send them into the league office and we
all said all right can't wait for you to
release that information because it's
going to show you the team who play with
footballs in the tens and 11 and then at
the end of the year when that
information was in they said no we never
never actually kept any information
which says the referees ignored the
actual game protocol which is no way
they all did so look the ball the
footballs weren't deflated at the time
if you didn't understand ideal gas law
and I bet I probably was I slept through
science class that day in high school
because I didn't know that much about it
um you would have fought an 11-point for
football with a massive cheating but it
isn't it's just December or January
football in the Northeast and I think
that's the big thing they could have
launched a huge investigation we could
be finding out what's on Ben
Roethlisberger cell phone right now
heavens a bit we could have every guy in
the staff getting grilled we aren't and
so I think the NFL knows they did it
wrong against to England I think they
should apologize Tom Brady I don't
really care about the draft pick or
anything like that the Bradys reputation
got creamed on this thing and in no way
could you can you pin this on him thank
you Dan good to talk to you again exam
that's Dan Wetzel yahoo sports columnist
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]